- Welcome to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools for everyday life.
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor of
neurobiology and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, my guest is Dr. David Anderson,
Dr. Anderson is a professor of biology
at the California Institute of Technology,
often commonly referred
to as Caltech University.
Dr. Anderson's research
focuses on emotions
and states of mind and body,
and indeed he emphasizes how emotions,
like happiness, sadness, anger and so on,
are actually subcategories
of what are generally governed by states,
that is, things that are occurring
in the nervous system in our brain
and in the connections
between brain and body
that dictate whether or not
we feel good about how we are feeling,
and that drive our behaviors,
that is, bias us to be
in action or inaction
and strongly influence
the way we interpret
our experience and our surroundings.
Today, Dr. Anderson
teaches us, for instance,
why people become aggressive
and why that aggression can
sometimes take the form of rage.
We also talk about sexual behavior,
and the boundaries and overlap
between aggression and sexual behavior.
And that discussion about
aggression and sexual behavior
also starts to focus on particular aspects
of neural circuits and
states of mind and body
that govern things like, for instance,
male-male aggression,
versus male-female aggression,
versus female-female aggression.
So today, you will learn a lot
about the biological mechanisms
that govern why we feel the way we feel.
Indeed, Dr. Anderson is an author
of a terrific new popular book,
entitled "The Nature of the
Beast: How Emotions Guide Us".
I've read this book several times now,
I can tell you it contains so many gems
that are firmly grounded
in the scientific research.
In fact, a lot of what's in the book
contrasts with many of the common myths
about emotions and biology.
So whether or not you're a therapist,
or you're a biologist,
or you're simply just somebody interested
in why we feel the way we feel
and why we act the way we act,
I cannot recommend the book highly enough.
Again, the title is
"The Nature of the Beast:
How Emotions Guide Us".
Today's discussion also
ventures into topics
such as mental health and mental illness,
and some of the exciting discoveries
that have been made by
Dr. Anderson's laboratory
and other laboratories
identifying specific peptides,
that is, small proteins
that can govern whether or not people
feel anxious or less anxious,
aggressive or less aggressive.
This is an important area of research
that has direct implications
for much of what we
read about in the news,
both unfortunate and fortunate events,
and that will no doubt drive the future
of mental health treatments.
Dr. Anderson is considered
one of the most pioneering
and important researchers
in neurobiology of our time.
Indeed, he is a member of the
National Academy of Sciences
and a Howard Hughes Medical
Institute investigator.
I've mentioned the HHMI
once or twice before
when we've had other HHMI
guests on this podcast,
but for those of you
that are not familiar,
the Howard Hughes Medical Institute
funds a small number of investigators
doing particularly
high-risk, high-benefit work,
and it is an extremely competitive process
to identify those Howard
Hughes investigators.
They are essentially appointed,
and then every five years,
they have to compete against one another
and against a new incoming flock
of would-be HHMI investigators
to get another five years of funding.
They are literally given
a grade every five years
as to whether or not they
can continue, not continue,
or whether or not they should worry
about being funded for an
extended period of time.
Dr. Anderson has been an investigator
with the Howard Hughes
Medical Institute since 1989.
I'm pleased to announce that
the Huberman Lab Podcast
is now partnered with
Momentous supplements.
We partnered with Momentous
for several important reasons.
First of all, they ship internationally,
because we know that
many of you are located
outside of the United States.
Second of all, and perhaps most important,
the quality of their
supplements is second to none,
both in terms of purity
and precision of the
amounts of the ingredients.
Third, we've really emphasized supplements
that are single-ingredient supplements,
and that are supplied in dosages
that allow you to build a
supplementation protocol
that's optimized for cost,
that's optimized for effectiveness,
and that you can add things
and remove things from your protocol
in a way that's really
systematic and scientific.
If you'd like to see the supplements
that we partner with Momentous on,
you can go to livemomentous.com/huberman.
There, you'll see those supplements,
and just keep in mind that
we are constantly expanding
the library of supplements
available through Momentous
on a regular basis.
Again, that's livemomentous.com/huberman.
Before we begin, I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is
separate from my teaching
and research roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part
of my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science
and science-related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with that theme,
I'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is Levels,
Levels is a program that lets you see
how different foods affect your health
by giving you real-time
feedback on your diet
using a continuous glucose monitor.
One of the most important factors
governing our immediate
and long-term health
and indeed our ability to
think and focus clearly
is our blood glucose levels,
also referred to as blood sugar.
To maintain healthy energy
and focus throughout the day,
you want to keep your
blood glucose levels steady
and avoid peaks and crashes.
I first started using
Levels about a year ago
as a way to better understand
how specific foods,
food combinations,
exercise and supplements
impact my blood glucose levels,
and it's been tremendously informative.
In fact, it's changed and shaped
the way that I organize my entire day.
Levels even provides a simple score
after you eat a meal
so you can see how
different foods affect you
and develop a personalized
nutrition program
that's ideal for you.
So if you're interested in
learning more about Levels
and trying a continuous
glucose monitor yourself,
you can go to levels.link/huberman,
that's levels.link/huberman.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Helix Sleep.
Helix Sleep makes mattresses and pillows
that are of the absolute highest quality.
They also have some
really unique features,
because they are customized
to your unique sleep needs.
I've talked over and over
again on this podcast
and on other podcasts
about the fact that sleep
is the foundation of mental health,
physical health and performance,
there's just simply no other substitute
for a quality night's
sleep on a regular basis.
I've been sleeping on a Helix mattress
for well over a year now
and it's the best sleep
that I've ever had,
and that's in large part
because the mattress was designed for me.
What you need to know, however,
is what's the ideal mattress for you,
and you can do that by
going to Helix's site,
you can take their brief quiz,
which will ask you, "Do
you sleep on your side,
your back, your stomach?
Or maybe you don't know,
or maybe all three.
Do you tend to run hot
or cold in the night?
Maybe you know, maybe you don't."
At the end of that short quiz,
they will match you to the
ideal mattress for you.
I matched to the Dusk,
the D-U-S-K mattress,
but again, that's what I need,
that's not necessarily what you need
in order to get your best night's sleep.
But if you're interested
in upgrading your mattress,
go to helixsleep.com/huberman,
take their two-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a
customized mattress for you
and you'll get up to $200
off any mattress order
and two free pillows,
they have terrific pillows.
And you get to try out that mattress
for 100 nights risk free.
They'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it,
but I'm certain you will.
Again, if you're interested in it,
you go to helixsleep.com/huberman
for up to $200 off your mattress order
and two free pillows.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by LMNT.
LMNT is an electrolyte drink
that has everything you need
and nothing you don't, meaning no sugar,
but it has sodium, magnesium and potassium
in the proper ratios.
Sodium, magnesium and potassium
are critical for the
functioning of all your cells,
but of your neurons, your
nerve cells in particular.
Many people out there, believe it or not,
need to ingest more
sodium and more potassium,
and magnesium in the proper ratios
to sodium and potassium.
For those of you that are
prehypertensive or hypertensive,
you definitely don't want to
crank up your sodium intake,
but many people out there,
especially people following low-carb diets
or eating exceptionally clean
very well may need more sodium.
And by drinking LMNT mixed with water,
which is what I do once or twice a day,
and certainly also during
workouts and after workouts,
you can optimize mental functioning
and physical performance
by increasing your electrolyte
balance in the proper ratios.
If you'd like to try LMNT,
you can go to drinklmnt,
that's L-M-N-T, .com/huberman,
and you'll get a free
sample pack with your order.
Again, that's drinklmnt.com/huberman
to get a free sample pack with your order.
And now for my discussion
with Dr. David Anderson.
David, great to be here
and great to finally sit
down and chat with you.
- Great to be here too, thank you so much.
- Yeah, I have a ton of questions,
but I want to start with
something fairly basic,
but that I'm aware is a
pretty vast landscape,
and that's the difference
between emotions and states,
if indeed there is a difference,
and how we should think about emotions.
What are they?
They have all these names,
happiness, sadness,
depression, anger, rage,
how should we think about them
and why might states be
at least as useful a thing to think about,
if not more useful?
- That's great.
First, the short answer to your question
is that I see emotions as
a type of internal state,
in the sense that arousal's
also a type of internal state,
motivation's a type of internal state,
sleep is a type of internal state.
And the sort of simplest way
I think of internal states is that,
as you've shown in your own work,
they change the input-to-output
transformation of the brain.
When you're asleep, you
don't hear something
that you would hear if you were awake,
unless it's a really, really loud noise.
So from that broad perspective,
I see emotion as a class of state
that controls behavior.
The reason I think it's useful
to think about it as a state
is it puts the focus on it
as a neurobiological process
rather than as a psychological process.
And this gets around all of
the definitional problems
that people have with the word emotion,
where many people equate
emotion with feeling,
which is a subjective sense
that we can only study in humans,
because to find out
what someone's feeling,
you have to ask them,
and people are the only
animals that can talk,
that we can understand.
So that's how I think about emotion,
if you think of an iceberg,
it's the part of the iceberg
that's below the surface of the water,
the feeling part is the tip
that's sort of floating above
the surface of your consciousness.
Not that that isn't important, it is,
but you have to understand consciousness
if you want to understand feelings,
and we're not ready to
study that in animals yet,
and so that's how I think about it.
- What are the different
components of a state?
You mentioned arousal as a key component,
what are some of the
other features of states
that represent this, as you so
beautifully put in your book,
that represent below the tip
of the iceberg?
- Right, right.
So you can break states
up into different facets,
or people would call them dimensions,
and so there have been people
who have thought of emotions
as having just really two dimensions,
an arousal dimension, how intense is it?
And also a valence dimension,
which is, is it positive
or negative, good or bad?
Ralph Adolphs and I have tried
to expand that a little bit
to think about components of emotion,
particularly those that
distinguish emotion states
from motivational states,
because they are very closely related.
One of those important
properties is persistence,
and this is something that distinguishes
state-driven behaviors
from simple reflexes.
Reflexes tend to terminate
when the stimulus turns off,
like the doctor hitting
your knee with a hammer,
it initiates with the stimulus onset
and it terminates with
the stimulus offset,
emotions tend to outlast, often,
the stimulus that evoke them.
If you're walking along a trail
here in Southern California,
you hear a rattlesnake rattling,
you're going to jump in the air,
but your heart is going
to continue to beat
and your palms sweat and
your mouth is going to be dry
for a while after it's
slithered off in the bush,
and you're going to be hypervigilant,
if you see something
that even remotely looks
snake-like, a stick,
you're going to stop and jump.
So persistence is an important
feature of emotion states,
not all states have persistence.
So for example, you think about hunger.
Once you've eaten, the state is gone,
you're not hungry anymore,
but if you are really angry
and you get into a fight with somebody,
even after the fight is over,
you may remain riled up for a long time
and it takes you a while to calm down,
and that may have to do
with the arousal dimension
or some other part of it.
And then generalization
is an important component of
emotion states that make them,
if they have been
triggered in one situation,
they can apply to another situation.
And my favorite example of that is,
you come home from work
and your kid is screaming,
if you had a good day at work,
you might pick it up and sooth it,
and if you had a bad day at work,
you might react very differently
to it and scream at it.
And so that's a generalization
of the state that was triggered at work,
by something your boss said to you,
to a completely different interaction.
And again, that's something
that distinguishes
emotion states from motivation states,
motivation states are really specific,
find and eat food,
obtain and consume water,
and they're involved in
homeostatic maintenance.
So states are very multifaceted,
and just asking questions
about how these components
of states are encoded,
like what makes a state persist?
What gives a state a positive
or a negative valance?
How do you crank up or crank down
the intensity of the state?
It just opens up a
whole bunch of questions
that you can ask in the brain
with the kinds of tools we have now.
- You mentioned arousal a few times,
and you mentioned valence,
realizing that there are
these other aspects of states,
I'd like to just talk about
arousal a little bit more, and valence,
because at a very basic level,
it seems to me that arousal,
we can be very alert and pissed off,
stressed, worried, we can have insomnia,
we can also be very
alert and be quite happy.
So the valence flips, people
can be sexually aroused,
people can be aroused
in all sorts of ways.
Is there any simple or simple-ish
neurochemical signature
that can flip valence?
So for instance, is there any
way that we can safely say
that arousal with some
additional dopamine release
is going to be of positive valence,
and arousal with very low dopamine
is going to be of negative valence?
- I would be reluctant to say
that it's a chemical flip,
I would say it's more likely to be
a circuit flip.
- Mm-hmm.
- Different circuits being engaged.
And it might be that a given
neurochemical, even dopamine,
is involved in both
positively valanced arousal
and negatively valanced arousal,
that's why people think about
these as different axes.
So I think the interesting
question that you touch on is,
is arousal something that
is just completely generic
in the brain,
or are there actually
different kinds of arousal
that are specific to different behaviors?
And you raise the question,
sexual arousal feels different
from aggressive arousal, for example,
and we actually published a paper on this,
back in 2009, in fruit flies,
where we found some evidence
for two types of arousal states.
One of which is sleep-wake arousal,
you're more aroused when you wake up
than when you're asleep,
and flies show that,
and the other is a startle response,
an arousal response to
a mechanical stimulus,
and not just mechanical stimulus.
If you puff air on flies,
kind of like trying to swat the wasp away
from your burger at a picnic table,
they come back more and
more and more vigorously.
And we were able to dissect this
and show that although both
of those forms of arousal
required dopamine, they were exerted
through completely separable
neural circuits in the fly.
And so that really put, number one,
the emphasis on it's the circuit
that determines the type of arousal,
but also that arousal isn't unitary,
that there are behavior-specific
forms of arousal.
And I think the jury is still out
as to whether there is such a thing
as completely generalized arousal or not.
And I think some people
would argue there is,
but I think more attention needs
to be paid to this question
of domain-specific or
behavior-specific forms of arousal.
- Yeah, it's a super-interesting idea,
'cause I always thought of
arousal as along a continuum,
like you can either be in a panic attack
at the one end of the extreme,
or you can be in a coma,
and then somewhere in the
middle, you're alert and calm,
but then this issue of
valence really, as you say,
presents this opportunity
that really there might be
multiple circuits for arousal.
- Yeah.
- Or multiple mechanisms
that would include
neurochemicals, as well as
different neural pathways.
- Yeah.
- So like to talk a bit about a state,
if it is indeed a state,
which is aggression,
your labs worked extensively on this.
And if you would, could you highlight
some of the key findings there,
which brain areas that are involved?
The beautiful work of Dayu
Lin and others in your lab
that point to the idea
that indeed there are kind
of switches in the brain,
but that thinking of
switches for aggression
might be too simple,
how should we think about aggression?
And I'll just sort of skew the question
a bit more by saying,
we see lots of different
kinds of aggression,
this terrible school shooting
down in Texas recently,
clearly an act that included aggression,
and yet, you could imagine
that's a very different type of aggression
than an all-out rage or
a controlled aggression,
there's a lot of variation there.
So what are your thoughts on aggression,
how it's generated, the
neural circuit mechanisms
and some of the variation
in what we call aggression?
- Yeah, this is a great question,
and it's a large area.
I would say that, first of all,
the word aggression, in my mind,
refers more to a description of behavior
than it does to an internal state.
Aggression could reflect an internal state
that we would call anger in humans,
or could reflect fear,
or it could reflect hunger
if it's predatory aggression.
And so this gets at the
issue that you raised
of the different types
of aggression that exist.
The work that Dayu did
when she was in my lab
that really broke open the field
to the application of modern genetic tools
for studying circuits in mice
is that she found a way to
evoke aggression in mice
using optogenetics to
activate specific neurons
in a region of the hypothalamus,
the ventromedial hypothalamus, VMH,
which people had been studying
and looking at for decades,
following, first, the work of,
in cats, the famous
Nobel Prize-winning work
of Walter Hess,
and then followed by work
done by Menno Kruk, in
the Netherlands, in rats,
where they would stick
electrical wires into the brain
and send electric currents into the brain,
and they could trigger a placid cat
to suddenly bare its teeth, hiss
and almost strike out at the experimenter,
and they could trigger rats
to fight with each other.
And even in Hess's original experiments,
he describes two types of aggression
that he evokes from cats
depending on where in the hypothalamus
he puts his electrode,
one of which he calls defensive rage,
that's the ears laid back,
teeth bared and hissing.
And the other one is predatory aggression,
where the cat has its ears forward,
and it's batting with its
paw at a mouse-like object,
like it wants to catch it and eat it.
So he already had, at that stage,
some information about
segregation in the brain
of different forms of aggression.
So fast forward to 2008, 2009,
when Dayu came to the lab
and we had started working
on aggression in fruit flies,
and I wanted to bring it into mice
so that we could apply genetic tools.
And we started by having Dayu,
who was an electrophysiologist,
just repeat the electrical stimulation
of the ventromedial
hypothalamus in the mouse,
just like people had done in rats,
in cats, in hamsters, even in monkeys.
And she could not get
that experiment to work
over 40 different trials,
it just didn't work.
What she got instead was fear behaviors,
she got freezing, cornering and crouching.
And finally, in desperation,
and we got a lot of input
from Menno Kruk on this,
he really was mystified,
"Why doesn't it work in mice?"
We realized why there had been no paper
on brain-stimulated aggression
in mice in 50 years,
'cause the experiment doesn't work.
And the one bit of
credit I can claim there
is I convinced Dayu to try optogenetics,
because it just had sort of
come into use deep in the brain,
from Karl Deisseroth and others' work.
And I thought maybe because it could be
directed more specifically
to a region of the brain
and types of cells than
electrical stimulation,
it might work.
And Dayu said, "Never,
never going to work.
If it doesn't work with electricity,
why should it work with optogenetics?"
And the fact is that it did work,
and we were able to trigger
aggression in this region
using optogenetic stimulation
of ventromedial hypothalamus.
And in retrospect, I think the reason
that we were seeing all
these fear behaviors
is because right at the upper part,
if you think of ventromedial hypothalamus
like a pear sitting on the ground,
the fat part of the pear near the ground
is where the aggression neurons are,
but the upper part of the
pear has fear neurons.
And it could be because
it's so small in a mouse,
when you inject electrical
current anywhere in the pear,
it flows up through the entire pear
and it activates the fear circuits,
and those totally dominate aggression.
And so that's why we
were never able to see
any fighting with electrical stimulation,
whereas when you use optogenetics,
you confine the stimulation
just to the region
where you've implanted
the channelrhodopsin gene
into those neurons.
And so fast forward from that,
from a lot of work from
Dayu now on her own at NYU,
and with her postdoc, Annegret Falkner,
as well as work of other people,
there's evidence that the type of fighting
that we elicit when we stimulate VMH
is offensive aggression
that is actually rewarding to male mice.
- They like it.
- They like it,
male mice will learn to poke their nose
or press a bar to get the opportunity
to beat up a subordinate male mouse.
And in more recent experiments,
if you activate those neurons
and the mouse has a chance to be
in one of two compartments in a box,
they will gravitate
towards the compartment
where those neurons are activated,
it has a positive valance.
And when I went into this field
and I was thinking, "Well,
what goes on in my brain
and my body when I'm furious?"
it certainly doesn't feel
like a rewarding experience,
it's not something that
I would want to repeat
because it feels good
when I'm in that state,
it doesn't feel good at
all when I'm in that state.
And it is still, I think, a mystery
as to where that type of aggression,
which is more defensive aggression,
the kind of aggression you
feel if you're being attacked
or if you've been cheated by somebody,
where that is encoded in the
brain and how that works,
still, I think, is a
very important mystery
that we haven't solved.
And predatory aggression there
has been some progress on,
so mice show predatory aggression,
they use that to catch
crickets that they eat,
and that involves different circuits
than the ventromedial
hypothalamic circuits.
So it's become clear that,
if you want to call it
the state of aggressiveness,
is multifaceted,
it depends on the type of aggression
and it involves different
sorts of circuits.
There's a paper suggesting
that there might be a final common pathway
for all aggression in a region,
which is one of my favorites,
it's called the substantia innominata,
the substance with no name, I like.
- Anatomists are so creative.
- Yes.
[Andrew laughing]
Or the nucleus ambiguous,
or the zona incerta, these are places
that no one can think of what they are.
Anyhow, that might be
a final common pathway
for predatory aggression,
and offensive and defensive aggression,
but it can be really hard to tell
just from looking at a mouse fight
whether it's engaged in offensive
or defensive aggression.
We've tried to take that apart
using machine learning
analysis of behavior,
but in rats, for example,
it's much clearer when the animal
is engaged in offensive
versus defensive aggression.
They direct their bites
at different parts of the opponent's body.
- [Andrew] In particular.
- Offensive aggression is flank directed,
defensive aggression goes for the neck,
goes for the throat.
- Mm,
I've seen some nature specials
where in a very barbaric way,
[laughing] at least to me, it seems,
like hyenas will try and go
after the reproductive axis,
they'll go after testicles and penis
and they basically want to,
it seems they want to limit
future breeding potential.
- Yes, or create pain.
[David laughing]
- Right, or create pain,
or both.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, in terms
of offensive aggression
and your reflection that
it doesn't feel good,
I mean, I can say, I know some people
who really enjoy fighting.
- [David] Hmm.
- I have a relative who's a lawyer,
he loves to argue and fight.
- [David] Huh.
- I don't think of him
as physically aggressive,
in fact, he's not,
but loves to fight and loves to prosecute
and go after people.
- Hmm.
- And he's pretty effective at it.
- Right.
- I have a friend,
former military special operations,
and very calm guy, had a great career
in military special operations,
and he'll quite plainly
say, "I love to fight."
- Mm-hmm.
- "It's one my great joys."
He really enjoyed his work.
- [David] Yep.
- And also respected the other side
because they offered the
opportunity to test that
and to experience that joy.
So in a kind of bizarre
way to somebody like me,
who I'll certainly defend
my stance if I need to.
- Yeah.
- But I certainly
don't consider myself somebody
who offensively goes after
people just to go after them,
there's no, quote-unquote,
dopamine hit here.
- Right.
- Acknowledging that dopamine
does many things, of course.
- Yeah.
- I have couple of questions
about the way you describe the circuitry,
I should say, the way the
circuitry is arranged.
- [David] Mm-hmm.
- And of course, we don't know,
because we weren't consulted
at the design phase.
[David laughing]
But why do you think
there would be such a close
positioning of neurons
that can elicit such divergent
states and behaviors?
I mean, you're talking about
this pear-shaped structure,
where the neurons that generate fear
are cheek to jowl with the neurons
that generate offensive
aggression of all things.
It's like putting the neurons
that control swallowing
next to the neurons that control vomiting,
[laughing] it just seems to me that,
on the one hand, this is the way
that neural circuits are often arranged,
and yet, to me, it's
always been perplexing
as to why this would be the case.
- Yeah, I think that is
a very profound question,
and I've wondered about that a lot.
If you think from an
evolutionary perspective,
it might have been the case
that defensive behaviors and fear
arose before offensive aggression,
because animals, first and foremost,
have to defend themselves from
predation by other animals.
And maybe it's only
when they're comfortable
with having warded off predation
and made themselves safe,
that they can start to think about,
"Who's going to be the alpha
male in my group here?"
And so it could be that if
you think that brain regions
and cell populations evolve by duplication
and modification of
preexisting cell populations,
that might be the way that those regions
wound up next to each other.
And developmentally, they start out
from a common pool of precursors
that expresses the same gene,
the fear neurons and
the aggression neurons,
and then with development,
it gets shut off in the aggression neurons
and maintained in the fear neurons.
Now, that view says, "Oh, it's an accident
of evolution and development,"
but I think there must be
a functional part as well.
So one thing we know
about offensive aggression
is that strong fear shuts it down,
whereas defensive
aggression, at least in rats,
is actually enhanced by fear.
It's one of the big differences
between defensive aggression
and offensive aggression.
And if you think about it,
if offensive aggression is
rewarding and pleasurable,
if you start to get really scared,
that tends to take the fun out of it,
and maybe these two regions
are close to each other
to facilitate inhibition of
aggression by the fear neurons.
We know for a fact that if
we deliberately stimulate
those fear neurons at the top of the pear,
when two animals are involved in a fight,
it just stops the fight dead in its tracks
and they go off into
the corner and freeze.
So at least hierarchically,
it seems like fear
is the dominant behavior
over offensive aggression,
and how that inhibition
would work is not clear,
'cause all these neurons
are pretty much excitatory,
they're almost all glutamatergic.
And so one of the interesting
questions for the future is,
how exactly does fear dominate over
and shut down offensive
aggression in the brain?
How does that work, is it all circuitry,
are there chemicals involved?
What's the mechanism and
when is it called into play?
But I think that's the way
I tend to think about why these neurons
are all mixed up together.
And it's not just fight and freezing,
or fight and flight,
there are also metabolic
neurons that are mixed together
in VMH as well.
- Mm-hmm.
Controlling body-wide metabolism?
- Yeah.
- Very interesting.
- There are neurons there
that respond to glucose,
when glucose goes up in your
bloodstream, they're activated,
and VMH has a whole history
in the field of obesity,
because if you destroy it
in a rat, you get a fat rat.
So the way most of the
world thinks about VMH
is they think about, "Oh, that's the thing
that keeps you from getting fat."
It's the anti-obesity area,
but in the area of social behavior,
we see it as a center
for control of aggression
and fear behaviors.
And again, why these
neurons and these functions,
I like to call them the four Fs,
feeding, freezing, fighting and mating.
- Mm-hmm.
- That they all seem to be
closely intermingled with each other,
maybe because crosstalk between them
is very important to
help the animal's brain
decide what behavior to prioritize
and what behavior to shut
down at any given moment.
- One of the things that we will do
is link to the incredible
videos of these mice
that have selective stimulation
of neurons in the VMH,
Dayu's and the other
studies that you've done.
Whenever I teach, I show
those videos at some point,
with the caveats and
warnings that are required
when one is about to
see a video of a mouse
trying to mate with another mouse,
or mating with another mouse,
and they seem both to be quite happy
about the mating experience,
at least as far as we
know, as observers of mice.
And then upon stimulation
of those VMH neurons,
one of the mice essentially
tries to kill the other mouse.
And then when that stimulation is stopped,
they basically go back to hanging out.
They don't go right back to mating.
- Right.
- There's some reconciliation
clearly that needs to
[laughing] happen first,
we assume.
- Yes.
- But it's just so striking,
and I think equally striking is the video
where the mouse is alone
in there with the glove,
the VMH neurons are stimulated
and the mouse goes into a rage,
it looks like it wants to kill
the glove, basically.
- Yep.
- So striking, I encourage
people to go watch those,
because it really puts a
tremendous amount of color
on what we're describing,
and it's just the idea that
there are switches in the brain,
to me, really became
clear upon seeing that.
One of the, excuse me, one of the concepts
that you've raised in your lectures before
and that I think was Hess's idea
is this idea of a sort
of hydraulic pressure.
- Mm-hmm.
- Or maybe it was Konrad,
I can't speak now.
[David laughing]
Excuse me, Konrad Lorenz,
pardon.
- Mm-hmm.
- Who talked about a kind
of hydraulic pressure
towards behavior.
I'm fascinated by this
idea of hydraulic pressure,
because I don't consider
myself a hot-tempered person,
but I am familiar with the fact
that when I lose my temper,
it takes quite a while
for me to simmer down.
I can't think about anything else,
I don't want to think about anything else.
In fact, trying to think
about anything else
becomes aversive to me,
which, to me, underscores
this notion of prioritization
of the different states.
- Mm-hmm.
- And potentially conflicting states.
What do you think funnels into this idea
of hydraulic pressure toward a state?
And why is it, perhaps, that
sometimes we can be very angry,
and if we succeed in winning an argument,
all of a sudden, it will subside?
Because clearly that means
that there are external influences,
it's a complex space
here that we're creating,
I realize I'm creating
a bit of a cloud.
- Yeah.
- And I'm doing it on
purpose, because, to me,
the idea of a hydraulic
pressure towards a state,
like sleep, there's a sleep pressure.
- Yeah.
- There is a pressure
towards aggression, that all makes sense,
but what's involved?
Is it too multifactorial
to actually separate out the variables,
but what's really driving
hydraulic pressure
toward a given state?
- Yeah, so really important question,
I think one way that is
helpful, at least for me,
to break this question
apart and think about it
is to distinguish homeostatic behaviors,
that is, need-based behaviors,
where the pressure is
built up because of a need,
like, "I'm hungry, I need to eat.
I'm thirsty, I need to drink.
I'm hot, I need to get to a cold place,"
it's basically the thermostat
model of your brain.
You have a set point,
and then if the temperature gets too hot,
you turn on the AC,
and if the temperature gets too cold,
you turn on the heater
and you put yourself
back to the set point.
I don't think that's how aggression works.
That is, it's not that we all go around,
at least subjectively,
I don't go around with an
accumulating need to fight,
which I then look for
an excuse to release it.
Now, maybe there are people that do that,
and they go out and look for
bar fights to get into to.
- Or Twitter.
- Yeah, [laughing] or Twitter,
yeah.
- Twitter seems to,
I'm sort of half joking,
because Twitter seems to draw
a reasonably sized crowd of people
that are there for combat of some sort,
even though the total intellectual power
of any of their comments
is about that of a cap gun.
[David laughing]
They seem to really like
to fire off that cap gun.
- Right, right.
- But I agree.
- Yeah.
- Before we continue
with today's discussion,
I'd like to just briefly acknowledge
our sponsor, Athletic
Greens, now called AG1.
Athletic Greens, aka AG1,
is an all-in-one,
vitamin-mineral probiotic drink
that also has adaptogens
and digestive enzymes.
I've been taking Athletic
Greens since way back in 2012,
so I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started
taking Athletic Greens
and the reason I still drink
Athletic Greens twice a day
is that it supplies total
foundational coverage
of my vitamin-mineral needs
and it supplies important nutrients
that I need to support my gut microbiome.
The gut microbiome, as many of you know,
supports the immune system,
it also supports the
so-called gut-brain access,
which is vital for
mood, for energy levels,
for regulating focus
and many other features
of our mental health
and physical health that
impact our daily performance
and high performance in any endeavors
we might be involved in.
If you'd like to try Athletic Greens,
you can go to athleticgreens.com/huberman
and claim a special offer.
They're giving away five free travel packs
plus a year's supply of
vitamin D3 K2 with every order.
And of course, vitamin D3 K2
are vital for all sorts of things,
like hormone health and metabolic health,
and K2 for cardiovascular
health and calcium regulation.
Again, you can go to
athleticgreens.com/huberman
to claim that special offer.
- So you can think of this
accumulated hydraulic pressure
either being based on something
that you were deprived of
creating an accumulating need,
or something that you want to do
building up a drive or
a pressure to do that,
and the natural way to think
about that, at least for me,
is as gradual increases in neural activity
in a particular region of the brain.
And so for example, in the
area of the hypothalamus
that controls feeding,
Scott Sternson and others have shown
that the hungrier you get,
the higher the level of activity
in that region in the brain,
and then when you eat, boom,
the activity goes right back down again.
And that state is actually
negatively valenced,
so it's like the animal, quote-unquote,
feels increasingly uncomfortable,
just like we feel
increasingly uncomfortable
the hungrier we are,
and then when we eat, it tamps it down,
but there is this increased activity.
And I think in the case of aggression,
our data and others show
that the more strongly you drive
this region of the brain optogenetically,
the more of just a hair trigger you need
to set the animal off to get it to fight.
Now, the interesting thing
is that if there is nothing
for the animal to attack,
it doesn't really do much
when you're stimulating this region.
It sort of wanders around
the cage a little bit more,
but it will not actually show overt attack
unless you put something in front of it.
And the same thing is true for the areas
we've described that
control mating behavior.
This is what Lindsay is working on,
you can stimulate those areas
'til you're blue in the face,
and the mouse just sort of wanders around,
but if you put another mouse in,
wham, he will try to mount that mouse,
if you put a kumquat in the cage.
[Andrew laughing]
He'll try to mount
the kumquat,
and so it becomes a sort
of any port in the storm.
So there is this idea that the drive
is building up pressure
that somehow needs to be released
where that pressure is
actually being exerted,
if you accept that it's increased activity
in some circuit or circuits someplace,
what is it pushing up against
that needs something else
to sort of unplug it in
the Lorenz hydraulic model?
That is, you don't see the behavior
until you release a valve on this bucket
and let the accumulated pressure flow out.
And that's one of the
things we're trying to study
in the context of the
mating behavior as well,
how does the information
that there's an object in front of you
come together with this drive state
that is generated by stimulating
these neurons in the hypothalamus to say,
"Okay, pull the trigger and go,
it's time to mate, it's time to attack?"
And we're just starting to get
some insights into that now.
- Fascinating, and I
should mention to people,
Dr. Anderson mentioned Lindsay,
Lindsay is a former
graduate student of mine
that's now a postdoc in David's lab.
And I haven't caught up with her recently
to hear about these experiments,
but they sound fascinating.
I would love to spend
some time on this issue
of why is it that a mouse
won't attack nothing,
but it'll attack even a glove,
and why it will only try and mate
if there's another mouse to mate with?
It's actually, I think,
fortunately for you,
you're not spending a lot of time
on Twitter and Instagram or YouTube,
but there's this whole online
community that exists now,
as far as I know, it's almost
exclusively young males
who are obsessed with this idea,
I'll just say it, it has
a name, it's called NoFap,
of no masturbation as a way
to maintain their motivation
to go out and actually seek mates.
Because of the ready availability
of online pornography.
- Huh.
- There's probably
a much larger population of young males
that are never actually
going out and seeking mates
because they're getting
porn addicted, et cetera.
There's actually a serious issue
that came up in our episode
with Anna Lembke, who wrote the book
"Dopamine Nation".
- Hmm.
- Because of the
availability of pornography,
there's a whole social context
that's being created around
this, and genuine addiction.
So humans are not like the mice,
or mice are not like the humans,
humans seem to resolve
the issue on their own.
- Yeah.
- In ways that might actually
impede seeking and
finding of sexual partners
and/or long-term mates.
- Right.
- So serious issue there,
I raise it as a serious issue.
- Yep.
- That I hear a lot about,
'cause I get asked hundreds
if not thousands of questions about this,
"Is there any physiological basis
for what they call NoFap?"
And I never actually reply
'cause there's no data.
- [David] Yep.
- But what you're raising here
is a very interesting mechanistic scenario
that can, and as you
mentioned, is being explored.
So what do we know about the
internal state of a mouse
whose VMH is being stimulated
or a mouse whose other brain region
that can stimulate the desire to mate,
what do we know about the
internal state of that mouse
if it's just alone in the
cage wandering around?
iI it wandering around
really wanting to mate
and really wanting to fight?
We, of course, don't know,
but is its heart rate up,
is its blood pressure up?
Is it wishing that there was pornography?
[David and Andrew laughing]
Something's going on, presumably,
that's different than
prior to that stimulation,
and is it arousal?
And what do you think it is
about the visual factory
perception of a conspecific
that ungates this tremendous
repertoire of behaviors?
- Right, that is a central question.
I can say, at least with
respect to the fear neurons
that sit on top of the aggression neurons,
we know that when those neurons
are activated optogenetically,
in the same way we would
activate the aggression neurons,
that there's clearly an arousal
process that's occurring,
you can see the pupils
dilate in the animal.
There is an increase
in stress hormone release
into the bloodstream,
we've shown that heart rate goes up.
So in addition to the
drive to actually freeze,
which is what those animals do,
there is autonomic arousal
and neuroendocrine activation
of stress responses.
And some of that is probably shared
by the aggression neurons
and the mating neurons,
although we haven't investigated
it in as much detail,
but I wouldn't be surprised
because they project to
many of the same regions
that the fear neurons project to,
which is a interesting issue
in the context to discuss later maybe,
in the context of why we're comfortable
with mental illnesses that are based
on maladaptations of fear,
but not mental illnesses
that are based on
maladaptations of aggression
if they have pretty similar
circuits in the brain.
But that's how I would imagine
there is an arousal dimension, as you say,
there are stress hormones that
are activated, these regions,
VMH projects to about 30
different regions in the brain,
and it gets input from
about 30 different regions.
So I kind of see it as both an antenna
and a broadcasting center,
it's like a satellite dish
that takes in information
from different sensory modalities,
smell, maybe vision, mechanosensation,
and then it sort of
synthesizes and integrates that
into a fairly low-dimensional,
as the computational people call it,
representation of this pressure to attack,
and it broadcasts that all over the brain
to trigger all these systems
that have to be brought into play
if the animal is going
to engage in aggression.
Because aggression is a very risky thing
for an animal to engage in,
it could wind up losing
and it could wind up getting killed,
and so its brain constantly has to make
a cost-benefit analysis of
whether to continue on that path
or to back off as well.
And I think that part of
this broadcasting function
of this region is engaging
all these other brain domains
that play a role in this kind
of cost-benefit analysis.
- I want to talk more
about mating behavior,
but as a segue to that,
as we're talking about
aggression and mating behavior,
I think, "Hormones."
And whenever there's an
opportunity on this podcast
to shatter a common myth, I grab it.
One of the common myths that's out there,
and I think that persists,
is that testosterone makes
animals and humans aggressive,
and estrogen makes animals
placid and kind or emotional.
And as we both know,
nothing could be further from the truth,
although there's some truth to the idea
that these hormones are all involved.
Robert Sapolsky supplied
some information to me
when he came on this podcast,
that if you give people
exogenous testosterone,
it tends to make them more
of the way they were before.
If they were a jerk before,
they'll become more of a jerk,
if they were very altruistic,
they'll become more altruistic.
And then eventually I pointed out,
"You'll aromatize that
testosterone into estrogen
and you'll start getting
opposite effects,"
so it's a murky space,
it's not straightforward.
But if I'm not mistaken,
testosterone plays a role
in generating aggression,
however, the specific hormones
that are involved in
generating aggression via VMH
are things other than testosterone.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that?
'Cause there's some
interesting surprises in there.
- Yeah, that's a really
important question.
So when we finally
identified the neurons in VMH
that control aggression
with a molecular marker,
we found out that that marker
was the estrogen receptor.
So that might strike
you as a little strange,
why should aggression-promoting
neurons in male mice
be labeled with the estrogen receptor?
Other labs have shown
that the estrogen receptor
in adult male mice is
necessary for aggression.
If you knock out the gene in VMH,
they don't fight.
And it's been shown, and
a lot of this is work
from your colleague,
Nirao Shah, at Stanford,
who is one of my former PhD students,
that if you castrate a mouse
and it loses the ability to fight,
not only can you rescue fighting
with a testosterone implant,
but you can rescue it
with an estrogen implant.
So you can bypass
completely the requirement
for testosterone to restore
aggressiveness to the mice.
And as you say,
it's because many of the
effects of testosterone,
although not all, many
of them are mediated
by its conversion to estrogen,
by a process called aromatization,
it's carried out by an
enzyme called aromatase.
In fact, most of your listeners
may have heard of aromatase
'cause aromatase inhibitors are
widely used in female humans
as adjuvant chemotherapy
for breast cancer.
They are a way of reducing
the production of estrogen
by preventing testosterone
from being converted into estrogen.
And in fact, there are a
lot of animal experiments
showing if you give males
aromatase inhibitors,
they stop fighting,
as well as also stop
being sexually active.
And so that's one of the
counterintuitive ideas,
and Nirao has shown that progesterone
also seems to play a role in aggression,
because these aggression neurons
also express the progesterone receptor.
So here are two hormones that
are classically thought of
as female reproductive hormones,
this is what goes up and goes
down during the estrous cycle,
estrogen and progesterone,
and yet, they're playing
a very important role
in controlling aggression in male mice,
and presumably in male humans as well.
- Fascinating, so estrogen
is doing many more things
than I think most people believe.
- Yep.
- And testosterone is doing
maybe different and fewer
things in some cases,
and more in others.
I've known some aggressive females
over the time I've been alive,
what's involved in female aggression
that's unique from the pathways
that generate male aggression?
- Great question,
so we and other labs have
studied this in both mice
and also in fruit flies.
So one thing in mice that
distinguishes aggression
in females from males
is that male mice are
pretty much ready to fight
at the drop of a hat,
female mice only fight
when they are nurturing
and nursing their pups
after they've delivered a litter.
And there is a window there
where they become hyper-aggressive,
and then after their pups are weened,
that aggressiveness goes away.
So this is pretty remarkable
that you take a virgin female mouse
and expose it to a male,
and her response is to
become sexually receptive
and to mate with him.
And now you let her have her pups,
and you put the same male
or another male mouse
in the cage with her,
and instead of trying to mate
with him, she attacks him.
So there is some presumably hormonal
and also neuronal switch
that's occurring in the brain
that switches the response of the female
from sex to aggression
when she goes from virginity to maternity.
And we recently showed in a paper,
this is work from one of
my students, Mengyu Liu,
that within VMH in females,
there are two clearly divisible subsets
of estrogen receptor neurons,
and she showed that one of
those subsets controls fighting
and the other one controls mating.
And in fact, if you stimulate
the fighting-specific subset in a virgin,
you can get the virgin to attack,
which is something that we
were never able to do before,
and if you stimulate the
mating one, you enhance mating.
The reason we could
never get these results
when we stimulated the whole population
of estrogen receptor neurons
is that these effects are
opposite and they cancel out.
And so it turns out that
if you measure the activity
of the fighting and the mating neurons
going from a virgin to a maternal female,
the aggression neurons are
very low in their activity
in the virgin,
but once the female has pups,
the activation ability of
those neurons goes way up
and the mating neurons stay the same.
So if you think of the balance
between them like a seesaw,
in the virgin, there is more activity
in the mating neurons than
in the fighting neurons,
whereas in the nursing mother,
there's more activity or more activation
the other way around,
the fighting neurons in the mating.
- Mm-hmm.
- Did I say,
"Fighting and mating," the first?
Mating neurons dominate
fighting in the virgin,
fighting neurons dominate
mating in the mother.
So that's a really cool observation,
and it's not something
that happens in males,
and we don't know what
causes that or controls that.
Interestingly, this gets
into the whole issue
of neurons that are present
in females, but not in males.
So the field has known for a long time
that male and female fruit
flies have sex-specific neurons.
And most of the neurons
that we've identified
in fruit flies that
control fighting in males
are male specific,
they're not found in the female brain,
but recently, we discovered a set
of female-specific fighting
neurons in the female brain,
together with a couple
of other laboratories.
Now, they do share one
common population of neurons
in both male and female flies,
that in females,
activates the female-specific
fighting neurons,
and in males, activates the
male-specific fighting neurons,
so it's kind of a hierarchy
with this common neuron on top.
And in mice, we discovered
that there are male-specific
neurons in VMH,
and those neurons are activated
during male aggression.
Now, the neurons that
are active in females
when females fight in
VMH are not sex specific,
so they are also found in males.
So this is already showing
you some complexity,
the male mouse VMH
has both male-specific aggression neurons
and generic aggression neurons.
And then the female VMH,
the mating cells are
only found in females,
they are female specific
and not found in the male brain.
And so we're trying to find out
what these sex-specific
populations of neurons are doing,
but that indicates that that
is some of the mechanism
by which different sexes
show different behaviors.
- I'm fixated on this transition
from the virgin female mouse
to the maternal female mouse,
and I have a couple of
questions about whether or not,
for instance, the transition is governed
by the presence of pups.
So for instance, if you
take a virgin female,
she'll mate with a male,
once she's had pups,
she'll try and fight that
male, or presumably another
intruder female, right?
- Yes,
equally towards females
and male intruders.
- Does that require the
presence of her pups?
Meaning if you were to take those pups
and give them to another mother,
does she revert to the
more virgin-like behavior?
Is it triggered by lactation
or could it actually be triggered
by the mating behavior itself?
'Cause it's possible for the
virgin to become a non-virgin,
but not actually have a litter of pups.
- Right, those are all great questions,
and we don't know the
answer to most of them.
What I can say is that a nursing mother
doesn't have to have her
pups with her in the cage
in order to attack an intruder male
or an intruder female,
she is just in a state of brain
that makes her aggressive to any intruder.
And those aggression neurons
in that female's brain
are activated by both male
and female intruders equally,
whereas in male mice,
the aggression neurons
are only ever activated
by males, not by females,
because males are never
supposed to attack females,
they're only supposed to mate with them.
So that's another difference
in how those neurons are tuned
to signals from different conspecifics.
Does it require lactation?
I don't know the answer to that,
I think there are some experiments
where people have tried
to, classical experiments,
people have tried to reproduce
the changes in hormones
that occur during pregnancy in female rats
to see if it can make them aggressive.
And some of those manipulations
do, to some extent,
but there's a whole biology there
that remains to be explored
about how much of this is hormones,
how much of this is
circuitry and electricity,
and how much of it is other factors
that we haven't identified yet?
- I don't want to anthropomorphize,
but, well, I'll just ask the question.
So the other day, I was
watching ferrets mate, right?
They're mustelids, and
they're mating behavior,
I guess I didn't say
why I was watching this,
doesn't matter.
[David laughing]
It simply doesn't matter,
but if one observes the mating behaviors
of different animals,
we know that there's a tremendous range
of mating behaviors in humans.
There can be no aggressive component,
there could be an aggressive component
in humans that have all sorts of kinks
and fetishes and behaviors,
and most of which probably
has never been documented
'cause most of this happens in private.
And here, I always say on this podcast,
any time we're talking about
sexual behavior in humans,
we're always making the presumption
that it's consensual, age appropriate,
context appropriate and
species appropriate.
Well, today, we're talking about
a lot of different species.
With that said, just to set context,
I was watching this
video of ferrets mating,
and it's quite violent actually.
There's a lot of neck biting,
there's a lot of squealing.
If I were going to project
and anthropomorphize,
I'd say it's not really clear
they both want to be there,
one would make that assumption.
And of course, we don't
know, we have no idea,
this could be the ritual.
It seems, to me, that
there is some crossover
of aggression and mating
behavior circuitry
during the act of the mating,
and do you think that reflects
this sort of stew of competing neurons
that are prioritizing in real time?
Because, of course, as states,
they have persistence, as you point out,
and you can imagine
that states overlapping,
four different states,
the motivational drive to mate,
the motivational drive to get
away from this experience,
the motivational drive
to eat at some point,
to defecate at some point,
all of these things are competing,
and what we're really seeing
is a bias in probabilities.
But when you look at mating
behavior of various animals,
you see an aggressive component
sometimes, but not always.
Is it species specific,
is it context specific?
And more generally, do
you think that there
is crosstalk between these
different neuronal populations
and the animal itself
might be kind of confused
about what's going on?
- Right, great questions.
I can't really speak to the issue
of whether this is species specific,
'cause I'm not a
naturalist or a zoologist.
I've seen, like you have,
in the wild, for example,
lions when they mate,
I've seen them in Africa,
there's often a biting
component of that as well.
One of the things that surprised us
when we identified neurons in VMHvl
that control aggression in males
is that within that population,
there is a subset of neurons
that is activated by females
during male-female mating encounters.
Now, you don't generally think
of mouse sex as rough sex,
but there is a lot of what superficially
looks like violent behavior sometimes,
especially if the female
rejects the male and runs away.
And there's some evidence
that those female-selective neurons in VMH
are part of the mating behavior.
If you shut 'em down,
the animals don't mate as effectively
as they otherwise would.
What happens when you stimulate
them we don't yet know
because we don't have a
way to specifically do that
without activating the
male aggression neurons.
But I think they must
be there for a reason
because VMH is not
traditionally the brain region
to which male sexual
behavior has been assigned.
That's another area called
the medial preoptic area,
and there we have shown
that there are neurons
that definitely stimulate mating behavior.
In fact, if we activate those
mating neurons in a male
while it's in the middle
of attacking another male,
it will stop fighting,
start singing to that male
and start to try to mount that male
until we shut those neurons off.
So those are the
make-love-not-war neurons,
and VMH are the make-war-not-love neurons,
and there are dense interconnections
between these two nuclei,
which are very close to
each other in the brain.
And we've shown that
some of those connections
are mutually inhibitory,
to prevent the animal
from attacking a mate
that it's supposed to be mating with,
or to prevent it from
mating with an animal
it's supposed to be attacking.
But it's also possible
that there are some
cooperative interactions
between those structures,
as well as antagonistic interactions,
and the balance of whether
it's the cooperative
or antagonistic interactions
that are firing at any given moment
in a mating encounter, as you suggest,
may determine whether a
moment of coital bliss
among two lions may
suddenly turn into a snap
or a growl and a baring of fangs.
We don't know that,
but certainly the substrate,
the wiring is there
for that to happen.
- I'm sure people's minds are
running wild with all this.
I'll just use this as an opportunity
to raise something I've wondered about
for far too long, [laughing]
which is, I have a friend
who's a psychiatrist
who works on the treatment of fetishes.
This is not a psychiatrist
that I was treated by,
I'll just point that out.
[David laughing]
But they mentioned something
very interesting to me long ago,
which is that when you
look at true fetishes,
and what meets the criteria for fetish,
that there does seem to be some,
what one would think would
be competing circuitry
that suddenly becomes aligned.
For instance, avoidance of
feces, dead bodies, feet,
things that are very infectious,
typically those states of disgust
are antagonistic to the states of desire,
as one would hope is present
during sexual behavior.
Fetishes often involve
exactly those things
that are aversive, feet, dead bodies,
disgusting things to most people,
and true fetishes, in
the pathologic sense,
exist when people have,
basically, a requirement
for thinking about or even the presence
of those ordinarily disgusting things
in order to become sexually aroused.
- Hmm.
- As if the circuitry
has crossed over, and the
statement that wrung in my mind
was people don't develop
fetishes to mailboxes,
or to the color red, or to
random objects and things,
they develop fetishes to things
that are highly infectious
and counter-reproductive
appetitive states.
- Hmm.
- So I find that interesting,
I don't know if you have
any reflections on that
as to why that might be.
I'm tempted to ask whether or not
you've ever observed
fetish-like behavior in mice,
but I find it fascinating
that you have this area of the brain
that's so highly concerned
with the hypothalamus,
in which you have these
dense populations intermixed,
and that the addition of a
forebrain, especially in humans,
that can think and make decisions
could in some ways facilitate
the expression of these
primitive behaviors,
but could also complicate
the expression of primitive behaviors.
- Right, I would agree.
I think one way of looking at fetishes
from a neurobiological standpoint
is that they represent a kind
of appetitive conditioning
where something that is
natively aversive or disgusting,
by being repeatedly paired
with a rewarding experience,
changes its valence, its sign
so that now it somehow produces
the anticipation of reward
the next time a person sees it.
Now, I don't know that
literature in animals,
so I don't know if you could condition
a mouse to eat feces, for example,
although there are animals
that are naturally coprophagic,
and maybe mice do that
occasionally, I'm not sure.
But that is one way to think about it,
and that could certainly
involve in humans,
the more recently evolved
arts of the brain,
the cortex that is sort of orchestrating
both what behaviors are happening
and whether reward states are turning on
in association with those
behaviors that are happening.
And that's the part that
I think is difficult
and challenging to study in a mouse,
but certainly bears thinking about,
because it's a really interesting,
again, sort of counterintuitive aspect.
Again, like rough sex,
people that want to have fighting,
or violence, or aggressiveness
in order to be sexually
aroused, and fetishes.
And in fact, when we made
that discovery initially,
it raised the question in my mind
whether some people that are
serial rapists, for example,
and engage in sexual violence
might, in some level, have
their wires crossed in some way,
that these states that are supposed to be
pretty much separated and
mutually antagonistic are not,
and are actually more
rewarding and reinforcing.
I think it's going to be a long time
before we have figured it out,
but when you think about it,
there is no treatment
that we have for a violent sexual offender
that eliminates the violence,
but not the sexual desire and sexual urge,
whether it's physical castration
or chemical castration,
it eliminates both.
- Definitely an area that I think,
well, human neuroscience in general
needs a lot of tools, right?
In terms of how to probe and
manipulate neural circuitry.
I'd love to turn to this
area that you mentioned,
the medial preoptic area.
I'm fascinated by it, because
just as within the VMH,
you have these neurons for mating
and fighting, or aggression,
my understanding is medial preoptic area
contains neurons for mating,
but also for temperature regulation.
And perhaps I'm making
too much of a leap here,
but I've always wondered
about this phrase, "In heat,"
as certainly the menstrual and
or estrous cycle in females
is related to changes in body temperature.
In fact, measuring body temperature
is one way that women can fairly reliably
predict ovulation, et cetera.
Although this is not a
show about contraception,
please rely on multiple methods
[laughing] as necessary,
don't use this discussion as
your guide for contraception
based on temperature.
But if you stimulate certain neurons
in the medial preoptic area,
you can trigger dramatic
changes in body temperature
and/or mating behavior.
What's the relationship, if any,
between temperature and mating,
or do we simply not know?
- I don't know what the relationship
is between temperature and mating neurons
in the preoptic area.
I suspect that they are
different populations of neurons
because it's become pretty
clear that the preoptic area
has many different subsets of neurons
that are specifically active
during different behaviors,
even different phases of mating behavior.
So there are mounting neurons,
there are intromission thrusting neurons,
and ejaculation neurons
and sniffing neurons.
- Wait, wait, so I think
I've heard this before,
but I just want to make
sure that people get this
and I want to make sure I get this.
So you're telling me within
medial preoptic area,
there are specific neurons
that if you stimulate them,
will make males thrust
as if they're mating?
- No, so this is not based
on stimulation experiments.
- Mm.
- It's based on
imaging experiments right now.
- I see, I see.
- That we see when we
look in the preoptic area
at what neurons are active
during different phases of aggression,
we see that there are different neurons
that are active during sniffing, mounting,
thrusting and ejaculation,
and they become repeatedly activated
each time the animal
goes through that cycle.
- During mating, yeah.
- During the mating cycle.
There are also some neurons there
that are active during
aggression, which are distinct,
and we don't know whether those neurons
are there to promote aggression
or to inhibit mating when
animals are fighting.
We have some evidence that
suggest it may be the latter,
but we don't know for sure yet.
The thermosensitive neurons
are really interesting,
because you mentioned
the phrase, "In heat,"
and then in the context of aggression,
you talk about hotblooded
people or hotheads,
there's just recently a paper
showing there are thermoregulatory
neurons in VMH as well.
So all of these homeostatic systems
for metabolic control
and temperature control
are intermingled in these nuclei,
these zones that control these
basic survival behaviors,
like mating and aggression
and predator defense.
And I would imagine that
the thermal regulation
is tightly connected
to energy expenditure,
and that, again, these
neurons are mixed together
to facilitate integration
of all these signals
by the brain in some way
that we don't understand
to maintain the proper balance
between energy conservation
and energy consumption
during this particular
behavior or that behavior.
I mean, I've always been
fascinated by the question,
why is it that violence
goes up in the summertime
when the temperatures are high?
Does it really have something to do
with the idea that increased
temperature increases violence?
It seems hard to believe
because we're homeothermic
and we pretty much stay
around 98.6 Fahrenheit.
It could be other social
reasons why that happens,
people are outside, out on the street,
bumping into each other,
but I think there could well be something
that ties thermoregulation
to aggressiveness,
as well as to mating behavior.
- Fascinating, yeah.
I ask in the hopes that
maybe in the years to come
your lab will parse some of
the temperature relationships.
And I realize it could be also regulated
by hormones in general,
so it's tapping into two systems
for completely different reasons,
but anyway, an area that intrigues me,
because of this notion of hotheadedness.
- Right.
- Or cool, calm and collected.
And also the fact that,
and I probably should've
asked about this earlier,
that arousal itself is tethered
to the whole mating and
reproductive process.
I mean, without a sort of seesawing back
between the sympathetic
and parasympathetic
arousal, relaxed states,
there is no mating that will take place.
So it's fascinating the way
these different competing
forces and seesaws operate.
Several times during
the discussion so far,
we've hit on this idea
that the same behavior can
reflect different states,
and different states can converge
on multiple behaviors as well.
You had a paper not long
ago about mounting behavior,
which I found fascinating.
Maybe you could tell us about that result,
because, to me, it really speaks
to the fact that mounting behavior
can, in one context, be sexual,
and in another context,
actually be related to,
we presume, dominance.
And I think that my friends
who practice jujitsu,
when I talk about that result,
they say, "Of course,
mounting the other person
and dominating them,
there's nothing sexual about it,"
it's about overtaking them physically,
literally being on their neck side,
as opposed to lying on their own back.
- [David] Hmm.
- Just fascinating,
very primitive.
- Hmm.
- And yet, I think speaks to this idea
that mounting behavior might be
one of the most fundamental ways
in which animals and perhaps even humans
express dominance and/or
sexual interactions.
- Yep, and that's a fascinating question,
and it was harder to figure out
than you might've thought.
So there's been this debate
for a long time in the field,
when you see two male
mice mounting each other,
is this homosexual behavior,
is this a case of mistaken
sexual identification,
or is this dominance behavior?
And if you train an AI algorithm
to try to distinguish male-male mounting
from male-female mounting,
it does not do a very good job,
because motorically, those
behaviors look so similar.
And so how did we wind up figuring out
that most male-male mounting
is dominance mounting?
There are two important clues,
one is the context,
and so male-male mounting
tends to be more prominent among mice
when they haven't had a
lot of fighting experience.
And then as they become more
experienced in fighting,
they will show relatively less mounting
towards the other male and more attack,
and they'll transition quickly
from mounting to attack,
and so the mounting is always seen
in this context of an overall
aggressive interaction.
And then the second thing,
which, believe it or not, was suggested
by a computational,
theoretical person in my lab,
Ann Kennedy, who now has
her own lab at Northwestern.
She said, "Well, males are known to sing
when they mount females,
ultrasonic vocalizations,
why don't you see what kinds
of songs they're singing
when they're mounting males?
Maybe it's a different kind of song."
Well, what we found out is,
they don't sing at all when
they're mounting a male,
so you can easily distinguish
whether mounting behavior by a male mouse
is reproductive or agonistic, aggressive,
according to whether it's accompanied
by ultrasonic vocalizations or not.
And it turns out that
different brain regions
are maximally active
during these different types of mounting.
So VMH, the aggression locus
is actually active during
dominance mounting,
and you can stimulate
mounting, dominance mounting,
if you weakly activate VMH,
whereas MPOA is most strongly activated
during sexual mounting,
and that's always accompanied
by the ultrasonic vocalization.
So this shows how difficult
and dangerous it can be
to try to infer an animal's
state, or intent, or emotion,
from the behavior that it's exhibiting
because the same behavior can
mean very different things
depending on the context of the
interaction with the animal.
- And I would say, even more so
with when that animal is a
human or is multiple humans.
- That's right, and
there are many examples,
animals show chasing to obtain food,
a prey animal that they're
going to kill and eat,
and they show chasing to obtain a mate
that they're going to have sex with.
And so the intent of the
chasing is completely different,
and we don't know in all these cases
whether there are separate circuits
or common circuits that
are being activated.
- I'm obsessed with dogs and dog breeds
and et cetera, et cetera,
and one thing I can tell you
is that female dogs will mount and thrust.
We had a female pit bull
mix, a very sweet dog,
but in observing her,
it convinced me that one can never assume
that male dogs are more
aggressive than female dogs.
It turns out, in talking to people
who are quite skilled at dog
genetics and dog breeding,
that there's a dominance
hierarchy within a litter
and it crosses over
male-female delineations.
So you can get a female in the
litter that's very dominant
and a male that's very subordinate,
and no one really knows what relates to.
This is also why little dogs
sometimes will get right up in the face
of a big Doberman Pinscher.
- Mm.
- And just start barking,
which is an idiotic thing for it to do,
but they can be dominant
over a much larger dog.
- Hmm.
- Very strange,
to me anyway.
Female-female mounting,
do you observe it in mice?
Are there known circuits,
and what evokes female-female mounting,
or female-to-male mounting if it occurs?
- Good, yes, there are
clear examples of females
displaying male-type mounting behavior
towards other females.
We see this most commonly in the lab
where we are housing
females with their sisters,
say three or four in a cage,
we take one out and we
have her mate with a male,
where the male's doing the mounting,
now we take that female
and we put her back in the
cage with her litter mates
and she starts mounting them.
Now, what the function of that is,
if it has any function,
or what it means, what's
driving it, we don't know,
but we do know that if we stimulate
the neurons that control mounting in males
in the medial preoptic area,
if we stimulate that same
population in females,
it evokes male-type mounting
towards either a male or a female target.
In fact, we have a movie
where we have a female
that has just been mounted by a male,
so the male's on top and she's underneath,
and we stimulate that region
of MPOA in the female.
And she crawls out from
underneath the male
who has just mounted her,
circles around behind him
and climbs up on top of him
and starts to try to mount
him and thrust at him.
- That has a name online,
it's called a switch.
[Andrew laughing]
- Is that right? [laughing]
- [Andrew] Don't ask me how I know that.
- Okay.
- But it's a pretty, yeah,
it's a term that you hear.
You also hear the term
topping from the bottom,
which it sounds like
that is a literal topping
from the bottom.
- I see.
- That's a more of a psychological phrase,
from what I hear.
I have friends that are
educating me in this language,
mostly because I find
this kind of neurobiological
discussion fascinating.
And at some point, right?
I attempt, in my mind, to
superimpose observations
from the online communities.
- Yeah.
- That I'm told about
and asked about to this,
but I should point out,
it's always dangerous,
and in fact, inappropriate
to make a one-to-one link.
- Yes.
- Humans, they maintain all
the same neural circuitry
and pathways that we're
talking about today in mice,
but that forebrain does
allow for context, et cetera.
- Yep.
- Yeah.
- So what the function
is of female mounting,
I don't know, it could be a
type of dominance display.
It's hard to measure that
because people haven't worked
on female-dominance hierarchies
to the same extent that they've worked
on male-dominance hierarchies,
but it indicates that the
circuits for male-type mounting
are there in females,
as early work from Catherine
Dulac suggested some years ago.
- Fascinating, fascinating.
I love that paper because,
as you pointed out for chase,
for mounting behavior, we see it
and we think one thing specifically,
and after hearing this result,
actually, I'm not a big
fan of fight sports.
I watch them occasionally
'cause friends are into them,
but I've seen boxing matches, MMA matches,
where at the end of a round,
if someone felt that they dominated,
they will do the unsportsmanlike thing
of thrusting on the
back of the other person
before they get off.
- Really?
- Almost like, "I dominated you, and I'm,"
so mimicking sexual-like behavior,
but there's no reason to
think that it's sexual,
but they're sending a message.
- Yeah.
- Of dominance is what it implies.
I'd love to talk about something
slightly off from this circuitry,
but I think that's
related to the circuitry,
at least in some way,
which is this structure that
I've always been fascinated by
and I can't figure out
what the hell it's for,
'cause it seems to be
involved in everything,
which is the PAG, the periaqueductal gray,
which is a little bit
further back in the brain,
for people that don't know.
It's been studied in the context of pain,
it's been studied in the context
of the so-called lordosis response,
the receptivity or arching
of the back of the female
to receive intromission
and mating from the male.
How should we think about PAG?
Clearly, it can't be
involved in everything,
I'm guessing it's at least as complex
as some of these other regions
that we've been talking about,
different types of neurons
controlling different things,
but how does PAG play into this?
In particular, I want to know,
is there some mechanism of
pain modulation and control
during fighting and/or mating?
And the reason I ask is that,
while I'm not a combat sports person,
years ago, I did a little
bit of martial arts,
and it always was impressive to me
how little it hurt to get
punched during a fight
and how much it hurt
afterwards, [laughing] right?
So there clearly is some
endogenous pain control.
- Yep.
- That then wears off,
and then you feel beat up.
- [David] Yep.
- Or at least, in my case, I felt beat up.
What's PAG doing vis-a-vis pain,
and what's pain doing vis-a-vis
these other behaviors?
- Good, good.
So I think of PAG
like a old-fashioned
telephone switchboard,
where there are calls coming in,
and then the cables have to
be punched into the right hole
to get the information,
to be routed to the right
recipient on the other end of it,
because pretty much every
type of innate behavior
you can think of has
had the PAG implicated.
And there's a whole literature
showing the involvement
of the PAG in fear,
different regions of the PAG,
the dorsal PAG is involved
in panic-like behavior, running away,
the ventral PAG is involved
in freezing behavior.
Both the MPOA and VMH send
projections to the PAG,
to different regions of the PAG.
So in cross-section, I hate to say this,
but in cross-section, the
PAG kind of looks like
the water in a toilet
when you're standing
over an open toilet bowl.
- Mm-hmm.
- And if you imagine
a clock face projected onto that,
it's like the PAG has sectors,
from one to 12, maybe even more of them,
and in each of those sectors,
you find different neurons
from the hypothalamus are projecting.
So could turn out that there
is a topographic arrangement
along the dorsal-ventral axis of the PAG
and the medial-lateral axis of the PAG
that determines the type of behavior
that will be emitted when neurons
in that region are stimulated.
And I think sort of all of the evidence
is pointing in that direction,
but by no means, has it been mapped out.
Now, the thing that you
mentioned about it not hurting
when you got beat up during martial arts,
there is a well-known phenomenon
called fear-induced analgesia,
where when an animal is
in a high state of fear,
like if it's trying to defend itself,
there is a suppression of pain responses,
and I'm not sure completely
about the mechanisms
and how well that's understood,
but for example, the adrenal
gland has a peptide in it
that is released from the adrenal medulla,
which controls the
fight-or-flight responses,
and that peptide has analgesic activities.
Now, whether.
- May I ask what that
peptide is?
- It's called
bovine adrenal medullary peptide
of 22 amino acid residues.
And I only know about it
because it activates a receptor
that we discovered many years ago
that's involved in pain,
and we thought it promoted pain,
but it turns out that this
actually inhibits pain,
it's like an endogenous analgesic.
Whether this is happening,
this type of analgesia
is happening when an animal
is engaged in offensive aggression
or in mating behavior, I don't know,
but it certainly is possible.
And I don't know whether
these analgesic mechanisms
are happening in the PAG,
they could also be happening
a little further down
in the spinal cord.
The PAG is really continuous
with the spinal cord,
if you just follow it down
towards the tail of an animal,
you will wind up in the spinal cord.
And so it could be that
there are influences acting
at many levels on pain in the PAG
and in the spinal cord as well.
And it may well be known,
I just don't know it,
I want to distinguish
clearly between things
that are not known,
that I know are unknown,
which is in a fairly small
area where I have expertise,
from things that may be known,
but I'm ignorant of them,
because I just don't have a broad enough
knowledge base to know that.
- Sure, we appreciate those delineations.
Thank you, PAG, I think
this description of it
as an old-fashioned telephone switchboard,
and now every time I look into
the toilet, I'll think about
the periaqueductal gray.
- [laughing] That's right.
- [Andrew] And every time I see an image
of periaqueductal gray,
I'll think about a toilet.
- That's right. [laughing]
- That is an excellent description,
because, in fact, I drew a circle
with a little thing at the bottom.
And well, I'll put a post
or link to a picture of PAG
and you'll understand why
David and I are chuckling here,
because, indeed, it looks like a toilet,
when staring into a toilet.
Tell us about tachykinin,
I've talked about this a couple times
on different podcast episodes
because of its relationship
to social isolation,
and in part, because
the podcast was launched
during a time when there
was more social isolation.
My understanding is that tachykinin,
and you'll tell us what it is in a moment,
is present in flies
and mice and in humans,
and may do similar
things in those species.
- That's right, so
tachykinin refers to a family
of related neuropeptides.
So these are brain chemicals,
they're different from
dopamine and serotonin
in that they're not
small, organic molecules,
they're actually short pieces of protein
that are directly encoded by genes
that are active in specific neurons
and not in others.
And when those neurons are active,
those neuropeptides are released
together with classical transmitters,
like glutamate, whatever.
Tachykinins have been
famously implicated in pain,
particularly Tachykinin-I,
which is called Substance P,
one of the original pain modulating,
this is something that
promotes inflammatory pain.
But there are other tachykinin genes,
in mice, there are two,
in humans, I think there are three,
and in Drosophila, there's one.
And the way we got into tachykinins
is from studying aggression in flies.
We thought, since neuropeptides
have this remarkable parallel
evolutionary conservation
of structure and function,
like Neuropeptide Y controls feeding
in worms, in flies and mice and in people.
Oxytocin-like peptides
control reproduction
in worms and mice and in people.
We thought we might find
peptides that control aggression
in flies and in people,
and so we did a screen,
unbiased screen of peptides,
and found, indeed, that
one of the tachykinins,
Drosophila tachykinin, those
neurons when you activate them
strongly promote aggression,
and it depends on the
release of tachykinin.
Now, the interesting thing is that,
in flies, just like in people
and practically any other social animal
that shows aggression,
social isolation increases aggressiveness.
So putting a violent prisoner
in solitary confinement
is absolutely the worst,
most counterproductive thing
you could do to them.
And indeed, we found in flies
that social isolation increases the level
of tachykinin in the brain,
and if we shut that gene down,
it prevents the isolation
from increasing aggression.
So since my lab also works on mice,
it was natural to see whether tachykinins
might be upregulated in social isolation
and whether they play
a role in aggression.
And this is work done
by a former postdoc, Moriel Zelikowsky,
now at University of
Salt Lake City in Utah,
and she found, remarkably,
that when mice are socially
isolated for two weeks,
there is this massive upregulation
of Tachykinin-II in their brain.
In fact, if you tag the peptide
with a green fluorescent protein
from a jellyfish, genetically,
the brain looks green when
the mice are socially isolated
'cause there's so much
of this stuff released.
And she went on to show that
that increase in tachykinin
is responsible for the
effect of social isolation
to increase aggressiveness
and to increase fear
and to increase anxiety.
And in fact, there are drugs
that block the receptor for tachykinin
which were tested in humans and abandoned
because they had no efficacy
in the tests that they were analyzed for.
If you give those drugs to
a socially isolated mouse,
it blocks all of the
effects of social isolation.
It blocks the aggression,
it blocks the increased fear
and the increased anxiety,
and Moriel described it,
"The mice just look chill."
It's not a sedative,
which is really important,
it's not that the mice are going to sleep.
Most remarkably is, once
you socially isolate a mouse
and it becomes aggressive,
you can never put it back in its cage
with its brothers from its litter
because it will kill them all overnight,
but if you give it this drug,
which is called osanetant,
that blocks Tachykinin-II,
that mouse can be returned
to the cage with its brothers
and will not attack them,
and seems to be happy about
that for the rest of the time.
So this is an incredibly
powerful effect of this drug,
and I've been really interested
in trying to get pharmaceutical
companies to test this drug,
which has a really good
safety profile in humans,
in testing it in people
who are subjected to
social isolation stress
or bereavement stress.
And this is one of the areas
where I learned an eye-opening lesson,
as a basic scientist who naively thought
that if you make a discovery
and it has translational
applications to humans,
that pharmaceutical companies
are going to be falling all
over themselves to try it.
And they are not interested,
because once burned, twice shy,
these drugs were tested for
efficacy in schizophrenia.
I have no idea why,
there's very little preclinical
data to suggest that.
Not surprisingly, they failed.
When a drug fails in
clinical trials in Phase 3,
it costs $100 million to the company
that carried out that clinical trial.
So there's a huge slag heap
of discarded pharmaceuticals,
many of them inhibitors
of neuropeptide action,
that could be useful in other indications,
such as the one we discovered,
but there's a huge economic disincentive
for pharmaceutical companies
to test them again,
because the conclusion that they drew
from all these failed tests,
particularly in the 2010s and before that,
is that the reason they failed
is because animal experiments with drugs
don't predict how humans
will respond to the drugs,
and therefore, we shouldn't
try to extrapolate
from any other data that we
get from animal experiments,
mouse or rat experiments to humans,
because they'll lead us
down the wrong track,
and I think that that is probably wrong.
In some cases, it may be right,
but in other cases, there's
good reason to think,
because these brain regions and molecules
are so evolutionarily conserved
that they ought to be playing
a similar role in humans.
In fact, there is a paper showing that
in humans that have borderline
personality disorder,
there's a strong correlation
between their self-reported
level of aggressiveness
and serum levels of a tachykinin,
in this case, Tachykinin-I,
as detected by radioimmunoassay.
This is work of Emil Coccaro,
who's a clinical psychiatrist
at the University of Chicago.
So there is a smoking gun in
the case of humans as well.
And I was actually trying to interest
a pharmaceutical company
that was testing these drugs,
actually, for treatment of hot flashes
in females, in humans,
where there is actually good animal data
to think that it might be useful,
but I realized that this clinical trial
was going on during the COVID pandemic.
And I approached him and said,
"Look, nature may have
actually done for you
the experiment that I want you to do,
'cause some of the people
who are getting drug or placebo
are going to have been socially isolated
and some of them will have not.
Why don't you get them to
fill out questionnaires
and see whether the ones
who were given the drug
and socially isolated
felt less stressed and less anxious
than the ones who were
not socially isolated?"
And they would not touch it,
because they're in the
middle of a clinical trial
for a different indication for this drug,
and they have to report any observation
that they make about that drug
in their patient population.
So if they were to ask these questions
and get an unfavorable answer,
"Oh my God, I felt even worse
when I took this drug and I was isolated,"
they would be obliged to
report that to the FDA
and that could torpedo the chances
for the drug being approved
in the thing that it was
in clinical trials for.
So it's better not to ask and not to know
than it is to try to
find out more information
that could lead to another
clinical indication.
So I remain convinced
that this family of drugs
could have very powerful uses
in treating some forms
of stress-induced anxiety
or aggressiveness in humans,
but it's just very difficult,
for economic reasons,
to find a way to get
somebody to test that.
- Yeah, a true shame that
these companies won't do this,
and especially given the fact
that many of these drugs exist
and their safety profiles are established,
'cause that's always
a serious consideration.
- Yep.
- When embarking on a clinical trial.
Perhaps in hearing this discussion,
someone out there will understand
the key importance of this
and will reach out to us,
we'll provide ways to do that,
to get such a study going in humans.
Because I think if enough laboratories
ran small-scale clinical trials,
pharma certainly would
perk up their ears, right?
I mean, they're so strategic.
- Yep.
- Sometimes to their own.
- I mean, I would like to say also,
I'd like to see this tested on pets.
I mean, there's a huge
number of pets right now
that are suffering separation anxiety
because humans bought
them to keep them company
during the COVID pandemic,
and now they're home alone.
- And now they're home alone,
yeah.
- Okay?
And if this thing works in mice,
there's certainly a higher chance
it's going to work in dogs or in cats
than it is going to work in humans.
And if it did, that would
be even more encouragement
to continue along those lines.
People sometimes forget that
although we work on animals
and we ultimately want
to understand humans,
we care about how our results
apply to the welfare of animals as well,
and particularly domestic pets,
which is a multi-billion-dollar industry
in this country.
So if there is ways that they
can be made to feel better
when they're separated from their owners,
that would certainly be a good thing.
- Absolutely, we will put out the call,
we are putting out the call,
and I know for sure
there will be a response.
Just underscoring what we've
been talking about even more,
every time we hear
about a school shooting,
like in Texas recently,
or I happened to be in New York
during the time when there
was a subway shooting.
For whatever reason, I listened
to the book about Columbine,
that went into a very detailed way
about the origin of those
boys that committed that,
and every single time,
the person who commits those acts
is socially isolated,
as far as I know.
- Yeah, yeah.
- There might be some exceptions there.
And sometimes this crosses over
with other mental health issues,
but sometimes no, no apparent
mental health issues.
So social isolation clearly drives
powerful neurochemical and
neuro biological changes,
I really hope that Tachykinin-I and II,
those are the main ones
in humans?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Will be explored in more detail.
Also, I didn't know that
Tachykinin-I is Substance P.
- Yes.
- And Substance P
is Tachykinin-I.
- Yes.
Tachykinin-I is the gene name,
and Tachykinin-II, in humans,
is called Neurokinin B,
that's the name of the protein.
I just refer to it by the gene name
'cause it makes it easier
and I don't have to keep remembering
two names for each thing.
- And if I'm not mistaken,
you put yourself in the
company of geneticists
because your original
training was in genetics,
immunology and areas
related to that.
- It was in cell biology,
and I didn't actually have
formal training in genetics
as a graduate student,
but I think I'm a geneticist at heart,
that's just the way I like
to think about things.
And when I started working
on flies, that sort of,
I came out of the closet as a geneticist,
as it were. [laughing]
- Wonderful, as long as
we're talking about humans,
I'd love to get your thoughts
about human studies of emotion.
I know you wrote this
book with Ralph Adolphs,
you have this new book, which
we'll provide a link to,
which I've read front to
back twice, it's phenomenal.
- Thank you.
- I've mentioned it before
on the podcast, it's really,
there are books that are worth reading,
and then there are books
that are important,
and I think this book is truly important
for the general population
to read and understand,
and neuroscientists should read
and understand the contents,
because we, as a culture,
are way off in terms of
how we think about emotions
and states and behaviors.
So we'll put a link to that,
it's really worth the time
and energy to read it,
and it's written beautifully,
I should say.
- Thank you.
- Very accessible even for non-scientists.
There's a heat map diagram in
that book that I think about,
this is a heat map diagram
of subjective reports
that people gave of where
they experience an emotion,
or a feeling, a somatic feeling,
in their body, or in their head, or both,
when they are angry, sad, calm, lonely,
et cetera, et cetera.
And I wouldn't want people
to think that those heat maps
were generated by any
physiological measurement,
because they were not.
And yet, I don't think
we can have a discussion
about emotions and states
and the sorts of behaviors
that we're talking about today
without thinking about the body also.
- [David] Yep.
- And I'm not coming to this
as a Northern California, mind-body.
- Yeah.
- I've been to Esalen once.
[David laughing]
I didn't go in the baths,
I went there, I gave a talk and I left.
It is very beautiful.
If anyone wants to know
what it looks like,
I think that final scene of
"Mad Men" is shot at Esalen,
it's a very beautiful place.
And yet, mind-body, to me, is
a neurobiological construct.
- Yes.
- Because the nervous system
extends through out of the cranial vault
and into the spinal cord.
- Yeah.
- And body and back and forth, okay.
How should we think about
the body, in terms of states?
And at some point, I'd
love for you to comment
on that heat map experiment,
because it does seem that
there's some regularity
as to where people experience emotions.
When people are in a rage, for instance,
they seem to feel it both in
their gut and in their head,
it seems, on average.
And people love to
extrapolate to gut intuition
or that the chakras or
anger is in the stomach,
and this goes to Eastern
medicine, et cetera.
How should we think about mind-body
in the context of states,
and think about it as scientists,
maybe even as neuroscientists
or geneticists?
- Good, so for the answer
to the first question
about the heat maps
and people associating
certain parts of their body
with certain emotional feelings,
this goes back to something
called the somatic marker hypothesis,
that was proposed by Antonio Damasio,
who is a neurologist at USC,
the idea that our subjective feeling
of a particular emotion is,
in part, associated with a sensation
of something happening in a
particular part of our body,
the gut, the heart,
I don't see the liver
invoked very much in
emotional characterization,
but.
- But gall
and the gallbladder.
- Yes.
- Somebody having a lot of gall.
- That's right.
- I don't know why I make
a fist when I say that.
- Right.
- But I'm guessing
the gall bladder is shaped like a fist.
[Andrew laughing]
- That's right,
and if there is a physiology
underlying these heat maps,
it could reflect increased blood flow
to these different structures.
And that, in turn, reflects
what you were talking about,
that is, emotion definitely involves
communication between
the brain and the body,
and it's bidirectional communication,
and it's mediated by the
peripheral nervous system,
the sympathetic and the
parasympathetic nervous system,
which control heart rate, for example,
blood vessel, blood pressure.
And those neurons receive
input from the hypothalamus
and other brain regions,
central brain regions that
control their activity.
And when the brain is put
in a particular state,
it activates sympathetic
and parasympathetic neurons,
which have effects on the
heart and on blood pressure,
and these, in turn,
feed back onto the brain
through the sensory system.
And a large part of this
bidirectional communication
is also mediated through the vagus nerve,
which many of your listeners and viewers
may have heard about
because it's become a topic
of intense activity now.
People have known for a long time,
so the vagus nerve is a
bundle of nerve fibers
that comes out basically of your skull,
out of the central nervous system,
and then sends fibers
into your heart, your gut,
all sorts of visceral organs.
And that information is both,
you used the words
earlier in our discussion,
afferent and efferent.
So the vagal fibers sense things
that are happening in the body,
so the reason you feel your stomach
tied up in knots if you're tense
is that those vagal fibers
are sensing the contraction
of the gut muscles,
and they're also afferents,
which means that information
coming out of the brain
can influence those
peripheral organs as well.
And there's work from a number of labs,
just in the last six months or so,
where people are starting
to decode the components
of the different fibers
in the vagus nerve.
And it's amazing how much specificity is,
there are specific vagal
nerves that go to the lung,
that control breathing responses,
that go to the gut,
that go to other organs.
It's almost like a set
of color-coded lines,
labeled lines for those things.
And now how those vagal afferents
play a role in the playing
out of emotion states
is a fascinating question
that people are just beginning
to scrape the surface of.
But I think what's exciting now
is that people are going
to be developing tools
that will allow us to turn on or turn off
specific subsets of fibers
within the vagus nerve
and ask how that affects
particular emotional behaviors.
So you're absolutely right,
this brain-body connection is critical,
not just for the gut, but for the heart,
for the lungs, for all kinds
of other parts of your body,
and Darwin recognized that as well.
And I think it's a central
feature of emotion state,
and I think, what underlies
our subjective feelings of an emotion.
- Incredible, well, David, I have to say,
as a true fan of the work
that your lab has been
doing over so many decades,
and first of all, I was delighted
when you stopped working on stem cells.
[David laughing]
Not because you weren't doing
incredible work there,
but because I saw a talk
where you showed a movie of an octopus
spitting out, or not spitting,
but squirting out a bunch
of ink and escaping,
and you said you were going to work
on things of the sort that
we're talking about today,
fear, aggression, mating
behaviors, social behaviors.
It's been incredible to see the
work that your lab has done,
and I know I speak on behalf
of a tremendous number of people
when I say thank you for taking time
out of your important schedule
to share with us what you've learned.
My last question is a simple one,
which is, will you come back
and talk to us again in the future
about the additional
work that's sure to come?
- I would be happy to do that,
and I really have
appreciated your questions,
they've all been right on the money,
you've hit all of the
critical, important issues
in this field.
And you've uncovered what is known,
the little bit is known,
and how much is not known,
and I think it's important to
emphasize the unknown things,
because that's what the next
generation of neuroscientists
has to solve.
And so I hope this will help
to attract young people into this field,
because it's so important,
particularly for our
understanding of mental illness
and mental health and psychiatry,
we've got to figure
out how emotion systems
are controlled in a causal way
if we ever want to improve
on the psychiatric
treatments that we have now,
and that's going to require
the next generation of
people coming into the field.
- Absolutely, I second that.
Well, thank you, it's been a delight.
- Thank you, great, really appreciate it.
- Thank you for joining me today
for my discussion with Dr. David Anderson.
Please also be sure to
check out his new book,
"The Nature of the Beast:
How Emotions Guide Us".
It's a truly masterful exploration
of the biology and psychology
behind what we call emotions
and states of mind and body.
If you're learning from
and/or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to our YouTube channel,
that's a simple, zero-cost
way to support us.
Please also subscribe to the
podcast on Spotify and Apple,
and on both Spotify and Apple,
you have the opportunity to leave us
up to a five-star review.
If you have questions, or comments,
or suggestions about topics
you'd like us to cover,
or guests you'd like us to interview
on the Huberman Lab Podcast,
please put those in the
comment section on YouTube.
We do read all those comments
and we do take them to heart.
Please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning
of today's podcast,
and check out Momentous supplements,
our new partners in the supplement space,
and check out Athletic Greens,
that's the best way to
support this podcast.
If you're not already
following us on social media,
please do so.
We are hubermanlab on Twitter,
and we are also hubermanlab on Instagram.
And both places, I cover science
and science-related tools,
some of which overlap with the content
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
but much of which is
unique from the content
covered on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
Again, that's hubermanlab on Instagram
and hubermanlab on Twitter.
Please also check out our Neural
Network monthly newsletter.
This is a newsletter that has
summaries of podcast episodes,
it also includes a lot
of actionable protocols.
It's very easy to sign
up for the newsletter,
you go to hubermanlab.com,
click on the menu, go to Newsletter.
You supply your email,
but we do not share
your email with anybody,
we have a very clear and
rigorous privacy policy,
which is we do not share
your email with anybody.
And the newsletter comes out once a month,
and it is completely zero cost.
Again, just go to hubermanlab.com
and go to the Neural Network Newsletter.
I'd also like to point out
that the Huberman Lab
Podcast has a clips channel.
So these are brief clips,
anywhere from three to 10 minutes,
that encompass single concepts
and actionable protocols,
related to sleep, to focus,
interviews with various guests,
we talk about things like caffeine,
when to drink caffeine relative to sleep,
alcohol, when and how and
if anyone should ingest it
relative to sleep,
dopamine, serotonin, mental
health, physical health,
and on and on,
all the things that relate to the topics
most of interest to you.
You can find that easily
by going to YouTube,
look for, "Huberman Lab
Clips," in the search area,
and it will take you there, subscribe.
And we are constantly
updating those with new clips.
This is especially useful, I believe,
for people that have missed
some of the earlier episodes
or you're still working through
the back catalog of Huberman Lab podcasts,
which admittedly can be rather long.
And last but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.